good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we spend an awful lot of
time in the show night after night
trying to explain what is happening to
our country
and it's depressing a lot of the time
because the answer is always the same
america is not rotten
it's a great place the people who run it
are rotten
so you've been betrayed by the people
who lead you and that's why things are
so volatile
what you're looking at is a crisis of
our institutions our institutions are
corrupt some of them are collapsing
we say that a lot because it's true but
we should be more precise not all of our
institutions are the same
some of them are bad some of them are
awful but
looming above the rest is the worst of
all and that's the news media
they're the most corrupt how corrupt is
the news media
imagine a drunken teenage border guard
at the crossing between
togo and burkina faso shaking you down
at midnight as you pass through
the new york times is much more corrupt
than that
the media are more crooked than jimmy
hoffa ever was they're more dishonest
than your average bribe-taking building
inspector in queens
they're more treacherous than the mafia
they make cops and tijuana look
trustworthy
you'll get a fairer treatment from an
inner city dmv than you would from cnn
ask nick sandman we could go on words
can barely
express the truth of it watching the
news on television makes you question
the system itself
in what version of quote meritocracy
could someone like chuck todd get rich
and famous
dumb and conventional now passes
impressive it's insulting
but rather than being insulted we've
decided to pause for a moment
and look at it a different way yes the
news media are profoundly dishonest all
of us
lie from time to time that's the human
condition but imagine if
lying was your job imagine forcing
yourself to tell lies
all day about everything in ways that
were so transparent and so outlandish
that there is no way that people
listening to you could possibly believe
anything you said then imagine doing
that again
and again and again every day of your
professional life
for your entire life could you do that
if you could cnn has an opening on the
media analysis desk call them
immediately
but if you're a non-sociopathic normal
person the answer obviously is no you
could not do that you could never lie
like that
so you've got to kind of respect the
people who can they're like
olympians in reverse they achieve feats
so
dishonorable that you gasp in horror as
you watch them
but at the same time you've got to
respect those skills
take a look at these gold medalists in
duplicity and ask yourself as you watch
could you say something like this with a
completely straight face
about kamala harris she's incredibly
successful and she does everything
professionally with the utmost integrity
kamala harris is independent successful
strong but she's also a devoted wife and
she's not ashamed of that
and i would say that her performance as
a running mate
uh was was flawless i mean other than
barack obama in my career i've not seen
anybody really
who came in with that kind of raw
material in that she fits the moment in
such a powerful way
she is what every working woman strives
to be
of course she's flawless kamala harris
is
everything women want to be false
hollow cunning consumed with political
power really a model for your daughters
make that woman vice president and so
they did
and on the night they did they
celebrated in fact celebration might be
two mile to word
what happened on cable television that
night is typically and by law
in a lot of places confined to bedrooms
and other private spaces
but that night they did it in public and
they were proud of it
he was prime time over on cnn how you
feeling
it's i almost can't talk right now
because of the emotion
everyone is welcome under this tent we
don't care who you are
we don't care if you voted for us or not
you're all part of this american
experiment
it was i was so overwhelmed to hear that
i don't care what people think if they
think i'm biased or not
i don't care and so i'm very emotional
so when you ask me how i'm feeling right
now
i'm sorry that's all i can tell you this
is how i feel right now
i am so happy to have this platform to
be able to do this i may not have it
after this
but i really don't care i am so
happy everyone is welcome under this
tent
they're all invited except the white
supremacists and the q and on people and
anyone else who disagrees with anything
we say
they're all going to jail but the rest
are more than welcome to stay and obey
our commands
it was that kind of night festive
good-hearted magnanimous
months later as the inauguration neared
and the biden family made its victorious
procession into the capital city
the mood lifted even higher i have
chills
wrote one editor at the new york times
she was feverish with joy
cnn rousted its poet laureate from lunch
and led him to the set to commemorate
this moment
here's the sonnet he wrote for the
occasion
those lights that are that are just
shooting out from the lincoln memorial
along the reflecting pool i look it's
like almost
extensions of joe biden's arms embracing
america not everyone is as poetic as
david chalian the man you just saw
that's why he's cnn's
political director an ordinary
journalist might not even have
noticed that joe biden's arms are like
twin beams of light shooting forth from
the reflecting pool
embracing america as a mother embraces a
child no an ordinary journalist might
simply have described joe biden's arms
as
toned and tawny and redelent of musk and
saddle leather
not everyone is david chalian but not
everyone needs to be david chalian the
thing about journalism is
it's not an individual achievement it's
about the group
in journalism it's the collective spirit
that matters
like synchronized swimmers or certain
species of insects
journalists move together in concert as
a herd
if you will when joe biden writes a
talking point they repeat it not just a
few of them but
all of them in precisely the same way
think of reporters as the north korean
gymnastics team
celebrating kim il-sung day in a soccer
stadium in pyongyang
they move as one watch this clip for
example
members of the press corps inform you
that this new group of politicians in
washington
is very different from any other group
of politicians in
all of human history unlike the rest of
them these people are committed to
something called
the truth president joe biden making it
clear his administration will be
nothing like his predecessors with a
focus on truth
science and transparency a commitment to
clarity
transparency science and truth of a
return of normalcy has the biden
administration vows truth and
transparency now
as the biden white house vows
transparency and truth when sharing
information with the american people
what does that mean we're going to talk
about it
as this white house promises to bring
truth and science back to the white
house
is getting back to the truth and valuing
the truth getting back to the truth
valuing the truth now there's a
refreshing concept who does that remind
you of by the way
we don't even patriarchal here but if
we're being totally honest that sounds a
lot like
dad a little blunt sometimes but honest
a straight shooter
solid reliable steady that's joe biden
above all joe biden's a family man took
the train back to wilmington
every night to the ten thousand square
foot estate a campaign donor bought from
an exchange for unregistered lobbying on
behalf of credit card companies
biden's not like the last guy joe
biden's family is refreshingly normal
there aren't any weird sex scandals or
protracted drug problems or ongoing
criminal investigations you've got to
worry about
want to know what the bidens are doing
this weekend a recent headline in
newsweek will tell you
quote joe biden wins in mario kart race
against granddaughter at camp david
it's wholesome stuff like that not
secretly lobbying for china not
impregnating strippers from arkansas
no they're playing mario kart with the
grandkids just like you
and at the heart of this great american
family is a love story
one man one woman in the fires of
passion that changed the course of our
history
not since anthony dine with cleopatra in
downtown antioch before they killed
themselves obviously
has a country witnessed a love story as
moving and poignant as jill and joe's
no ladies and gentlemen jill biden is
not joe's caretaker she isn't his nurse
she's his fully equal romantic partner
together they
are the wise and knowing parents of a
nation as a headline from politico on
valentine's day put it quote
historians and relationship experts
agree the first couple's romantic
gestures aren't just
genuine they're restorative so it's
official
the biden's affection is totally real
it's in no way
part of a slick pr campaign devised by
cynical consultants determined to hide
the president's senility by misdirection
not at all
their love is as real as climate change
the politico story begins this way
quote on a mission to rebuild
institutional norms and help
heal a hurting nation joe and jill biden
are trying something novel after four
years of the trumps
a little tenderness that's right america
a little tenderness
the biden's love is like medicine it's
more powerful than the covet vaccine and
you
only need one injection watch dr joy
reed prescribe a whole lot more of it
what a story though what a great love
story between
jill biden and joe biden it's just a
different
kind of marriage this is a love match
like the obamas were so i think that'll
be healing for the country too
yeah it will be the biden's love will be
healing for this country will make us
whole again
it might even stop looming
hyperinflation and keep the chinese navy
from
closing the south china sea to
international shipping that's the kind
of love it is
when you've got a love like that it
emits a magnetic
tug people can feel it they seek you out
like
pilgrims to bask in your healing rays
here is the scene on the white house
lawn just this weekend as reporters from
across the region threw down their
crutches
and approached america's reigning
apostle of love
hoping to graze the hem of his garment
and be healed
how do you extend that love story to the
american people that are feeling so down
right now so discouraged tell them there
is hope there's hope
you just have to stay strong this lifted
your spirits
i hope you didn't have to come out of
this earth when it was so damn cold
next time bring us coffee too
i wasn't sure you'd all be here we'll be
here
i love your dogs i'll bring the donuts
next friday if you come back
okay i'll tell you what i apologize here
i didn't i didn't i didn't even
i didn't even have a taste here come on
i promise you i'm gonna get in trouble i
don't have my mask
i gave you my word i didn't have
anything well thank you i appreciate it
i'll bring donuts i love your dog and
above all how can your love heal this
nation